in this our last episode of citizen
science versus the aliens of Peru
Jackson and I will measure the volume of
an elongated skull and compare it to
that of a normal human skull we do this
to test the claims made by Brian Forster
and guy on comm that the elongated
skulls are 25% larger than normal and
are therefore non-human in this video
you will learn about volume cubic
centimeters and a simplified version of
Archimedes principle most importantly
you will learn how to use science and
critical thinking for yourselves to test
the claims of conspiracy theorists on
the Internet you are watching episode 5
of citizen science versus the aliens of
Peru welcome everybody this is the
episode you've all been waiting for I am
here with my nephew Jackson yeah this is
the exciting episode this is where we're
going to actually measure the volume of
these skulls and we're going to see if
the volume of the elongated skull really
is 25% larger than the volume of the
normal skull if it is 25% larger I will
be intrigued if it's not I'm gonna say
that this is just a normal human most
likely a normal human with head binding
right so Jackson do you want to tell us
what volume is according to it versus
wait that's it but volume is how much
something takes space right how much
space something takes exactly volume is
how much space something takes so I have
here what is this centimeter this is a
cubic centimeter roughly I just made an
ass out of clay and we measure volume in
cubic centimeters sometimes we measure
it in milliliters they're actually the
same thing usually when we're measuring
liquid we measure it in milliliters we
just like to call them leaders instead
of
centimetres most of us don't use the
metric system yeah in science we use the
metric system we measure volume in
milliliters and so if something is 500
milliliters that means it's 500 of these
little cubes and that's how much space
it takes up and grams one milliliter of
water or one cubic centimeter of water
weighs one gram gold weighs more than
one gram and because of that when you
put gold in water it sinks
tell them the story but the guy who
figured out volume right Archimedes is
the man who figured out how to measure
the volume of irregular objects so we're
trying to measure the volume of these
skulls that's hard to do because you
know with this you can get a ruler and
you can measure oh it's one centimeter
by 1 centimeter by 1 centimeter oh
that's one cubic centimeter but it's
really hard to measure with a ruler
something like this it's an irregular
shape
Archimedes this was over 2200 years ago
he discovered this so he was actually
alive probably when this maybe when this
person was alive here because this
elongated skull is 2,000 years old yeah
in Peru and we don't know exactly the
date on this but we think somewhere
2,000 years old maybe slightly older so
she might have actually been alive at
same time is Archimedes but our
communities he was a scientist way back
in the day if you could call him that
he's a philosopher and he figured out
lots of stuff and he made there's this
thing called Archimedes principle
Archimedes rule you can measure the
volume of an object by setting it in
water you take a dish you fill it to the
very top with water then you set an
object in it and the amount of water
that spills over you can then measure
with something like this that actually
has lines to tell you how many
milliliters it is and the amount of
water that spills over is the exact same
as the volume of the object that you
dunked in that water he figured this out
by getting into the bathtub the story
goes that he figured this out by getting
into the bathtub and watching the water
rise and he was really excited about
this because the King had made a crown
had a crown made by a goldsmith
and it was supposed to be made out of
gold but the King heard a rumor that the
goldsmith mixed silver in with that gold
and the King was really upset about this
but he loved the crown he didn't want to
melt it what you could do is you could
weigh the crown because they already
knew how much gold weighed per cubic
centimeter so you could melt down the
crown into a cube and then measure it
with a ruler see how many cubic
centimeters it is and then weigh it and
see if it actually is pure gold or not
but since he liked it so much he wanted
he didn't they didn't know a way to do
it so then this guy who was in the
bathtub yes
yeah so they didn't want to melt the
crown to measure it but this guy
Archimedes he's in the bathtub he
noticed how this works and he got so
excited he screamed Eureka and he
started running down the street naked
just really excited about his discovery
that's the story we don't know yeah yeah
so they figured it out they measured the
crown and the crown was in fact too big
for how much it weighed that means that
there was silver added to the gold let's
just say the guy who made it had
terrible ending for himself yeah I don't
think things ended well for thee the
Goldsmith that lied right so yeah that
is the principle that we're going to be
using to measure these skulls we're
going to dump them in the skull ometer
3000 a skull ohmmeter 3000 and we're
gonna measure how much water comes out
when we dunk in these skulls what I've
made is I just put a tube right in here
we're gonna fill the water all the way
up to that tube till it starts to spill
out and we're gonna let it spill out
completely that's gonna zero our machine
here it's going to once once it's all
the way filled out that's going to tell
us that the water is right at the spill
line then we're going to take these
skulls and we're going to one-by-one
dump them in and then measure on here
how much volume we get so this is our
experiment
and the reason that we're doing this
experiment Jackson is to prove I think
there's a guy I'm on I forgot his name
but he thinks that this could be is 25%
Lockett larger like he said or he says
it could be an alien or like an angel
thing yeah well he's not saying that
it's an alien or an angel he's just
saying that it's 25% larger than a
normal human skull he says that because
of that it can't be human it can't be a
normal human and he's he's done a lot of
videos about this and he's actually I
don't want to pick on him too much
name's Brian Forster because he's
actually getting a lot of people excited
about paleontology and that's a good
thing right but he's he's really excited
he's jumping to some conclusions without
carefully examining things there a
little bit scientifically irresponsible
but that people get excited you know
that's fine so he says this is 25%
larger than a normal human I suspect so
he actually measured one he what he did
is he took rice and put it into the big
hole at the bottom of the skull and
filled up the brain cavity in one of his
skulls and he did the same with one of
his normal skulls and he said that the
elongated skull was 25% larger what I
suspect happened is that he had an
abnormally small normal skull that he
was measuring these two skulls they are
perfect casts made from real skulls this
elongated skull is actually the one that
Brien Foerster puts on the cover of his
book it's a really famous specimen it's
one of the most extreme ones that that's
out there and this skull comes from a
normal human and bone clones is the
company that made these and bone clones
chose this guy's skull to use because he
was a really typical human so this
should be a normal-sized skull and this
no right it certainly looks longer it
could be one more plus and that'd be
considered that one like a little bit
bigger yeah
now there's there is normal variation
between humans so if one of these is
slightly bigger than the other it's not
really that big of a deal but if one of
them is 25% bigger than the other that's
a good plus that's a big deal a good
scientist will demonstrate all of their
experiments so that other people can
repeat this at home if they think that
we're wrong right
because sometimes in science what we
realize is that sometimes people will
trick themselves and to come believe in
something that's false so on the front
of this bucket we have this phrase
nullius in verba it like something from
England that scientists use yes to say
that's the saying from the Royal Society
which is one of the oldest scientific
clubs you could say that is an existence
and that saying means take no one's word
take nobody's word for it in this
scientific club
whenever someone made a claim they had
to show every single piece of data that
they used to come to that conclusion so
that other people could read their paper
and say yeah I agree or no I don't agree
and they had to document everything so
perfectly that anyone could replicate
their experiment so that's what we're
doing here with this video this is all
easy anyone can do this at home all you
have to do is buy these skulls these
skull replicas which you can buy from
bone clones how much are they they're
kind of expensive I think this one's
like 200 bucks yeah and this one is like
they're really cool though because these
these things are perfect replicas of the
original now when we say take no one's
word for it one of the problems with
using replicas instead of the actual
skulls is that we're actually taking the
word of bone clones right we're kind of
trusting them right so that's one of the
weaknesses in this but bone clones what
they do for a living is they make skulls
that are perfectly accurate that's what
they depend on that's their bread and
butter so we have no reason to suspect
that they would have modified these but
that is one of the things that is a
weakness in our experiment and talking
about the weaknesses of an experiment is
what the people in the Royal Society do
as well when someone's actually trying
to do real science they will be very
clear with their audience about these
strengths and weaknesses of their
experiment what do you think is maybe
another possible weakness of our
experiment oh yeah so everyone has a
special kind of made skull this one is
just a different kind of skull no one
else would have that kind of same
structured skull right everybody's
unique right
in their own way so if we wanted to
really do good science we will want to
do more experiments with more skulls but
for a YouTube experiment I think it's
okay just to use two skulls but ideally
we would use hundreds of skulls we would
use hundreds of elongated skulls
hundreds of normal skulls and we would
get the averages and those would be what
the thing we would really care about but
you know for this experiment I think two
should be enough the other slight
weakness in our experiment is that we
cannot measure the inside of these
skulls because these are just casts and
the inside of the skull was not
perfectly made to match the original
specimens like like these yeah yeah and
what I did is I blocked up all the holes
in the skull you have lots of holes that
you know like your eyes there's a hole
goes back into your brain and I plugged
up all those holes with clay it's
actually it's actually this stuff which
is a gummy eraser that you can get at an
art store so I plugged up all the holes
with gummy erasers and I also filled
them with sand so it'd be really heavy
it's a little sink in the water and the
disadvantage of that is that we're
measuring not just the brain we're also
measuring like the teeth and everything
and she's missing a couple of teeth
she's missing like four and a half teeth
and I have calculated that's about five
cubic centimeters so we're gonna have to
add five cubic centimeters to whatever
data we get yeah so that's one of the
disadvantages the other disadvantage to
that is that all of the data that this
other guy Brien Foerster has done he's
been measuring the insides of the skulls
so we won't be able to compare our data
directly to his but we will be able to
tell if this is 25% larger than this one
that's that what that will come through
in this experiment unfortunately also
when other scientists do brain volume
experiments they measure the inside of
the skull so if we go back to the
literature the scientific literature and
try and compare our numbers to theirs
our numbers are going to be different
because we measured the whole skull not
just the inside of the skull so there we
go I think I think we've covered our
strengths and weaknesses of this
experiment
everybody known now knows how to measure
volume the volume of an irregular object
so let's zero out our machine
the Scola meter 3000 and let's let's get
doing our thing do you want to film me
do that we want to film things from
every angle so that people know that
we're not cheating here I'm just filling
to the line I don't want it to be
shaking much it just starts shaking we
can get the measurement can actually be
inaccurate if there's waves in the water
the measurement can be inaccurate this
isn't an absolute perfect method because
the water has surface tension and that
can cause a little bit of problems but
we should be accurate within a few cubic
centimeters our cup here has a line
every 20 cubic centimeters so our
measurements will be within 20 cubic
centimeters
that's how accurate will be like it
takes a while for this to trickle out
sounds like it's taking a pee you know
what are we missing Jackson
yeah it's white code time all right
thank you here we are we are now yes
some some bunch in there yeah well the
problem is he snapped and this came on
and this is an adult size okay not an
adult okay there we go that's all right
we are science' fied we can now be
trusted by the people that like to watch
Gaia
videos on Gaia calm by the way we should
probably charge them $10 a month for
watching our show because that's what
guy charges their people for their lie
is in mythology we're doing an actual
legitimate science we should actually
charge them more than $10 because our
stuffs real all right so which one
should we measure first we measure the
humanoid okay now make it so that the
camera can easily see the liquid we're
gonna do 10 drops of this for the human
10 drops of blue that way it's gonna be
easy to see when the water fills in here
it's warm do that here yeah do a slokas
scene counties drop
I can't one two
my kid just thank you
all right that is ten drops of blue just
to make it easier for people to see and
I want to show the walk up so here it is
all blocked up with this clay it's
actually rubber eraser and let's film
this know what I'm doing here dunking it
in two I'm going to block the nose a
little quick so that I can drop this in
all the way cuz what's gonna happen I
got to put my hand in for a second and I
don't want my hand to be measured so I'm
trying to gently put it in there so
there's no waves and now that I've done
that opening up the nozzle again what is
our measurement starting just Logan
that's about 140 ish ish taller oh yeah
there's bubbles I think there might be a
tiny bit of water getting into the skull
but so that's gonna make his volume a
little bit less than it is in real life
but I think we're okay because it's so
slow we're almost at 1,700 that middle
kinda medium line is 1,700 almost done
dripping it's always so slow isn't it at
the end it's done and look at that at
least in the middle of 1600 yeah so that
line right above it is 1,700 so we're at
about 1600 and it looks like ninety
because each one of these lines is ten
all right sorry is 20 so we're at about
1690 for the normal human skull or right
in between those two lines 1690 cubic
centimeters yeah approximately that's as
close as we can get in this with our
measuring tools here yeah let's show
this to people this is the normal human
skull that's how much how much volume
that normal human skull is
so to fill up with a lit up of the extra
water a little yeah we're gonna zero out
the machine again no beaker it'd be
crazy they're both the same like they're
they'd be both the same milliliters that
would be crazy huh yeah my suspicions
that they're gonna be fairly close but
he says that the elongated skull is 25%
larger than normal skull so let's do
some math while this is trickling down
let's do some math and figure out what
25% larger than 1690 milliliters would
be do you know how to do that
calculation involved no you actually
just you you do this number times 1.25
ever note that what's that I don't know
that no well we'll just use a calculator
so we got technology with us 1690 times
1.25 because 0.25 is 25% and 1 is 100 so
we want we want the normal skull plus
0.25 so we do it times 1.25 that's the
logic there and that equals 2112 point
five that's og big centimeters right
here yeah so if the long skull really is
25% larger than the normal skull it will
be two thousand one hundred and twelve
point five milliliters now our
measurement device isn't that accurate
so I would say that if we get up to at
least two thousand two thousand fifty
I'm gonna say this is significant we
need to look further into this okay so
I'm gonna be generous and say if we can
get to two thousand fifty milliliters
that seems I'm gonna say this is
phenomenal this is really cool that's
our target
hopefully that's our estimate yeah
hopefully she is that fantastic
dick and then we'll have to explore what
the heck kind of what's going on you
know it okay so this is still going here
if we do find that she is 25% larger
does that automatically mean that she's
an alien or an alien hybrid or what or
something not really why not I don't
know well we you know we learned before
that humans can have a whole variety of
head shapes right in sizes so maybe
she's just a really big headed person
yeah their tribe could have been like
with the females are taller than men but
you know it would it would be pretty
interesting if she was that big because
they say that you know there are lots of
these skulls and have lots of them
they're that big if she was that big we
don't want to start comparing all of the
skulls that are there in Peru and we
want to see if all of them are big and
if all of them are big that's
interesting maybe they have some sort of
genetic difference that makes them
larger than normal humans maybe they
maybe the cranial binding somehow
actually makes the head bigger that
wouldn't make sense yeah because the
like a still board on the person's head
yeah well in this case they would use
bind their heads with fabric and we
think there's some artifacts they
suggest that they did that so we don't
think that that should make their head
actually bigger we think it should
making it longer yes but not bigger we
think it should make it longer but also
narrower so because the brain will grow
until it's done that the skull will grow
to fit the brain as it's growing so once
the brains done growing the skull will
stop growing so this should be
normal-sized it should be you should
just be Miss shapen yeah so this is our
our machine is zeroed I'm gonna dump
this out in our excess water bucket I'm
gonna try and get all the drops out
close I can it's not and we're gonna do
the same we're gonna make her purple so
I'm gonna do five blue drops and five
red drops because we did ten blue drops
last time all right that should come out
purple that'll be cool here we go I
plugged her holes in the same way so her
nose is still open just like his was you
know we talked briefly about her missing
teeth we're gonna maybe six milliliters
because our mm down compared to his she
might have been older it's working it's
black making purple well yeah it'll get
more purple when it's more watered down
okay now once again I'm going to plug
this because in a minute dunk even my
whole hand in here to make sure that
she's set in there nice I'm gonna wait
till the waves go away and then I will
unplug it that's good there we've
started again
oh man this is suspenseful what's it
gonna be she gonna really be over 2,000
milliliters above our measuring yeah cuz
look how its kind of slowing down yeah
it's already slowing down although if it
makes it up to about where we were kind
of like it wouldn't really be that much
of an improvement yeah last time we're
at 16 1690 here hold a little bit more
stable so people can see 1690 s what we
were at before see if we get there it's
already slowing down but it it keeps
going quite a bit after it slows down so
she might be bigger than he is
they're purple alien oh man this is
exciting
there's no bubbles that makes you
there's no water leaking into her skull
so that's good that's giving her a
little bit of an edge over him he had
probably a couple drops they got into a
skull not much
but a couple of drops got into a skull
so that means they were lost in the
measurement SAR made him almost slightly
less than that should have been but not
much it's almost at the 106 4600 marker
okay well that's pretty close there's a
little design if you can see like the
little water thing going through yeah
that's cool good to feed you use me just
a plastic tube from Home Depot oh look
at that
it's slowing down it's not oh here
zoom in on this thing from this thing on
the tube we can watch those last drips
it's still going still going be careful
is it bump the table whatever yet what
are we oh man so suspenseful well we're
way lower yeah there's no bubbles coming
at all right yeah look show the audience
there's no bubbles coming up so there's
no no leaks careful not to shake the
table there's no leaks at all I mean she
is actually smaller
let's wait up we're done we're done he's
smaller what is she at she's at 1,600
and you know each one of those lines is
20 so 1620 40 1640 milliliters and a
milliliter is cubic centimeter same
thing dang she is not an alien spike oh
plus five plus six yeah so 1646 and he
was 1690 he's bigger that also could be
that she's a woman and since woman are
like their heads are tiny bit smaller
and men are usually have bigger heads
that could be why right we have noticed
we have noticed if you look at all the
experiments on head size we have noticed
that men not always but typically have a
slightly larger head than women and the
reason for that is that men are taller
than women it's one of the reasons for
that and the taller that you are the
bigger your head is so so this is
actually not very surprising that he was
slightly larger than hers but it is
surprising because it means that she's
really there's no reason to think that
she's an alien there's no reason to
think she is just a normal person that
had cranial binding on her head that is
the most likely conclusion she looks
bigger but that's an illusion so there
you have it folks
the baracus skulls are not larger than
normal human skulls
at least this baracus skull is not
larger than this normal human skull
because we don't have hundreds and
hundreds right oh that would have been a
lot of money yeah unless you're the guy
who made an Amazon that'd be a spendin
Mike yeah well the company that makes
these only has like I think three
elongated skulls that they've made
because they have in order to make these
skulls what they do is they take they
actually take the specimen they use it
as a cast yeah and then they have to
give it back so you just ship the skull
across the world actually good legs put
this into a link or you could like see
the like you could press on the video if
you see it yeah yeah we're gonna have in
the video description we will have a
link where you can see how bond clones
makes their skulls you'll see them
they're actually doing a saber-tooth
tiger in the video and you
see how that process works it's I would
say that this myth is then debunked I
don't think I don't think that there is
no reason to suspect that she is an
alien she's just a normal human full
weird head with a weird-shaped head yes
because it was bound when she was a baby
that's incredible because I mean look at
this it really is it really is
impressive to know that this this
amazingly bizarre shaped head was
produced by simply binding the skull of
a baby that is incredible
so while it is sad that she's not an
alien we can still be happy with this
what this is amazing it teaches us so
much about how plastic living creatures
are we can we grow to fill the space
that we're given that's amazing and to
think that she lived to adulthood so
obviously if there was a brain damage
caused by this it wasn't severe she
lived to adulthood
so pretty incredible specimen any final
words of wisdom Jackson really take no
one's word that's that's what I'm gonna
say take no one's word I mean that's a
little bit cynical when doing science
take no one's word obviously you can
trust your friends and neighbors unless
they tell you something crazy like that
we found aliens in Peru but yeah so long
for now you know tag along keep keep
truckin stay curious so long for now
thank you yes yeah all right high five
Jackson that was fun
you took off your gloves now the guy
people aren't gonna trust you they're
gonna think that you lied to him great
well you did say in the video all right
we did it we made a great show
but this one is actually smaller
[Music]
you